like buried treasure they lie hidden
from sight echos of an ancient pass they
whisper secrets until tales once lost to
time fossils are remnants or impressions
of ancient organisms that are naturally
preserved in stone while there are
hundreds of fossil types they are often
grouped into two major categories body
fossils which are the preserved remains
of plants and animals and trace fossils
which are records of an animal's
behavior such as footprints together
they form the fossil record a primary
account that tells the story of life on
earth through stone fossilisation or the
process of preserving organisms in stone
can occur in countless ways these
methods are largely grouped depending on
whether the organisms are altered during
the fossilization process fossilisation
that does not alter a specimen can help
to preserve its original form and
texture among many methods this group
includes organisms that have been frozen
preserved in Tar Pits and mummified one
special case involves trapping organisms
oftentimes insects in amber this process
begins when an organism is covered in
tree sap the sap or resin forms a
protective seal around the entrapped
organism over time the soft resin
hardens and turns and to Amber with the
organism suspended within this process
creates a biologically inert tune for
the organism allowing its soft tissues
to be remarkably preserved
other fossilization methods change the
specimen as it is being preserved for
instance carbonization transforms soft
tissues into thin black films of carbon
in fact countless layers of carbonized
plant material create a well known
fossil fuel coal but one of the most
common types of fossilization that
changes a specimen is called
permineralization permineralization
begins when minerals from water or the
ground enter the pores of dead plant or
animal material over time the minerals
attach themselves coming on to cellular
walls and building a crystalline network
and the empty cavities this
mineralization hardens the bone and
turns it into stone thereby preserving
its original structure and fossil form
when conditions are right fossilization
can preserve crucial information about
an organism per mineralized would often
contains enough information to identify
its tree genus and sometimes its species
insects encased in amber have been so
well preserved that their genetic
material was extracted and partially
sequenced and footprints left behind by
ancient hominins helped paint a picture
of what life was like for early human
ancestors millions of years ago with
every fossil uncovered the planet's
ancient past becomes clearer helping
shape our understanding of our world
today
[Music]
you
[Music]